24 year old man remaining in police
custody after causing traffic to shut
down at a major roadway for several
hours during rush hour yesterday we
brought it to you on 8 news now Wilson
Reyes was scheduled to appear in court
today on several charges Joshua peguero
was there and joins us now from our
Newsroom with the very latest Joshua so
Reyes refused to appear before a judge
today he was uncooperative and officers
had a problem transferring him to court
according to court documents our eight
news now investigators obtained Reyes
drove his car into the curb narrowly
hitting an officer and a person with a
stroller this incident led to this
traffic backup Wednesday on Flamingo and
Koval police say officers order race to
stop following a cab near the link hotel
but he refused to comply he then
allegedly drove onto Las Vegas Boulevard
driving on the sidewalk to avoid being
arrested officers eventually performed
the pit maneuver and stopped his car at
Flamingo and Koval that's when police
say he began gassing his car up causing
his tires to spin and smoke a half hour
later officers forcibly removed Mayas
Reyes from the car when they caught on
fire flames then spread to nearby patrol
car now Reyes refused talking to
officers on scene and was taken to the
hospital he's scheduled to appear in
court next week live in The Newsroom
Joshua progero 8 News Now